I lose my ability to think straight or
intelligently and confrontational or
unfriendly social situations.
Any suggestions for
adoptation or approvement?
Well,
a couple I suppose.
One is,
is that when you get nervous in this
Hannah's situation that you're describing,
what often happens to people as they
start paying attention to themselves,
they get self conscious.
So you know,
let's say I got self conscious all
of a sudden during this Q and a,
what would happen is that I'd stopped
paying attention to the questions and the
screen and what I'm doing and I'd start
paying attention to how I was feeling
and to the nervousness.
And then I'd start to get aware that
I was not responding properly and that
would make me more nervous.
And then I would get more aware of that
and that can just shut me down entirely.
And that's happened to me now.
And then in a lecture and sometimes
almost happened when I was talking to Sam
Harris the first time.
Um,
I,
I paused for a long time and
then became aware of the pause.
And then anyways,
what you have to do in a situation like
that is it's not so much that you have
to stop attending to yourself because
if you start thinking I should stop
attending to myself,
then you'll just think
about yourself more.
What you have to do instead is pay more
attention to this situation and to the
people that you're talking to.
So you have to increase the degree to
which you're at attending outwardly and
that'll stop you from attending inwardly.
Um,
that's very effective technique.
You can practice that.
Generally speaking,
every time you get nervous,
start paying more attention and that'll,
that'll,
that'll help you out a lot.
Um,
the,
the really good suggestion for social
anxiety in general is that if you see most
people,
but not everyone,
but most people have enough implicit
social skill because they were reasonably
socialized when they were children so
that they do know how to act in social
situations,
but they get anxious and
then that interferes with
them implementing what they
know.
Just like if you're a pianist and you
get anxious and self conscious while
you're playing,
you'll forget what you know.
Because while you've activated
a different part of your brain,
if you can remember to pay attention and
you can direct your attention outward
and you attend hard enough,
then what will happen?
And try to put the other person at
ease and try to ask them questions,
then that'll kick in the automatic because
you're paying attention to what the
person is doing and to their
facial expressions and all of that,
that will clue in the
automatic and implicit,
uh,
knowledge that you have and make
things much more smooth and,
and,
uh,
and anxiety free.
So attention really attention really
plays a huge role in regulating anxiety.